Things don't go smoothly
when you're around people like this,
they shake things up.
So you need to ask yourself, what
is it you want from your society?
Are you happy being...
Are things good enough?
Is the status quo
satisfactory enough
that you can all sit back
and privilege agreeableness,
and say, "let's just all abide
by the rules of civility,
and everything will be fine"?
Or do you think, actually,
there's much to be gained,
as a society,
if we do change up
the status quo,
and introduce an element of friction
into the way we all behave.
What can we do as a society
that allows people to express
their disagreeableness?
Are there ways in which we could make
dissents, deviation, disagreement
just more palatable,
more easier to do?
In the workplace, what do we think
of as the role of a manager?
Is the role of a manager
to tolerate dissent?
Or find a safe place
for dissent?
Or to obliterate dissent?
A lot of managers actually try very,
very hard to obliterate dissent.
They think that that's how
their success ought to be measured.
Whereas this would
suggest actually no,
maybe what we want
from managers
is that people
who ought to be managers
ought to be the people
who have the thickest skins.
Ones who are just more...
Who are the most comfortable
with some degree of friction
in those who are under
their control.
And I think that's about how
do you structure education
so that children are taught that
it's OK sometimes to be rebellious
or questioning or sceptical?
Or that our willingness to
tolerate disruptive behaviour
in people of our own kind,
is far greater than our willingness
to tolerate in minorities.
In those who are powerless.
And what that leads to
is not just higher levels
of punitive action
towards people in
disadvantaged groups,
but also disadvantaged
groups themselves
changing their behaviour
to meet those different norms.
So you see among, for example,
in this country,
African-American parents,
who privilege good behaviour
in their own children as the most...
As kind of the primary
end-point of childhood,
Whereas you see parents
who are in the majority,
who will privilege achievements,
good performance,
as the primary end-point.
You're going to privilege
performance over behaviour,
if you're in the group that
is allowed to behave
in unusual, disruptive,
disagreeable ways.
And I think that is an
unacknowledged source
of a great deal of inequity
in modern life.
That we just have these
different standards
for people on the inside
and people on the outside.